um so unions threatening this strike
have threatened to um planning this
strike and threaten to shut down the
entire web network and that is pretty
much exactly what will happen i've just
come out of a meeting with bosses at
network rail who are in negotiations
with the rmt union trying to call this
strike off and they have said that only
20 percent of normal services will be
running on those strike days june 21st
23rd and 25th uh next week not all lines
will be running though only half of the
lines will will have services on them
and they have published this map
um which i will hold up for you to have
a look at you might not be able to make
out um the individual lines but the
purple lines you should be able to see
are the ones that will be operating and
you can see that in wales there's very
little at all nothing west or pretty
much nothing north of cardiff
nothing to holly head at all in scotland
nothing north of
edinburgh and glasgow in the south west
there's nothing west of plymouth nothing
going to to dorset either although
services will be running to castle carry
for glastonbury festival so anyone's got
a ticket there will probably be
breathing a big sigh of relief but on
those lines that are
running services will be dramatically
curtailed so only running between 7 30
in the morning and 6 30 and in the
evening but last trains
will be leaving a lot earlier than that
in order to reach their destinations to
beat that cutoff so for example we've
got a timetable of some of the last
trains um
from london to edinburgh the last train
will be leaving at two o'clock so much
much earlier than normal um to
manchester leaving london at 3 40
from cardiff going to london leaving at
3 54.
now those are the strike days but
network rail have warned that this
three-day action is actually going to
lead to six days of disruption because
the days immediately following each
strike day will also be affected with um
services running at about 60 percent
it's billed as the biggest strike
in modern times since since the 1980s
1990s and it's certainly looking like
that and at the middle of all this of
course is passengers they're being
warned to check before you travel plan
for disruption and if you can just don't
travel at all